where he actually got a chance to listen
to that
to the
to visit the masjid i've decided to
return to cairo to try and understand
who god is to muslims
islam believes in the same god as jews
and christians
but i want to know if there are
differences in how they think about the
divine
historian of islam ahmad ragab has
brought me to the al hussein mosque
and you can just come in here just like
the catholic church so it's always open
to prayer yeah if you want to come in
here and
you can hang out with the
yourself and allah yeah absolutely
i'm just in time to hear what muslims
believe is one of the most beautiful
sounds in the world
the call to prayer
[Music]
what do you think morgan freeman if we
all i mean we can end up dying tomorrow
before him we don't know when our death
date departure date is but if uh if we
just go by years he's uh closer than
than most of us right so now he's got to
hear
uh
some of the
teachings of islam if we if we have to
send the message to morgan freeman and
then uh maybe if he was to visit your
area of the world maybe he can come also
visit with you
and uh in his next documentary series
well first of all yani we wish and hope
for all
humans to accept islam regardless of
their position of the rank of their
fame
now uh having said that morgan freeman
i think
was doing this documentary uh for a
purpose
and he wasn't doing it for him own self
so he has a script
and he's following the script if they
were to take him to a hindu temple he
would have said what was in the script
like what's his name this uh
i have a certain skills uh that i will
know how to get you and i don't know how
to kill you uh lithium linum
nissan when he was in turkey yes some
something like that so he they praised
that he was so impressed with azan and
later on he was yeah
i mean it's part of the job
so we wish that they all come to islam
we wish that they come and ask us and
debate us and ask us what what islam is
i i don't like this in your religion no
problem
i'll clarify it to you they have so many
scholars or diaries or students of
knowledge around them they can get in
touch with but they don't
because this is their lifestyle
if
you you read the sunnah the prophet isam
sent to hercules or to the
emperor of the byzantines a message
the prophet as i've sent him a message
when this
ruler this emperor read the message said
he is on the right path and if i were
next to him i would have taken his shoes
and washed his feet and drank the water
of that so people ask him okay
are you accepting islam said no no no i
was just testing the people
the prophet said that islam he
did
not want to waste his empire
so
he knew that accepting islam means
losing all the wealth
losing all the power losing losing his
empire
so he
decided to keep that over
that thing is done most celebrities are
like this who wants to let go of all the
wealth and fame
for
claiming that oh islam is beautiful
you have to submit your will you're not
able to do this so unfortunately but
yeah sure thing anyone who wants to come
and talk to me or let alone i wouldn't
say talk to me talk to someone who's
more knowledgeable talk to scholars talk
to someone who you may benefit from but
if they want to come and talk to this
poor slave of allah i'm always there and
just a phone call away
let's go back to this now this is
historical people go reference this
check it up heracles now so this is this
was a ruler at that time so he's exposed
to
islam he's exposed to the last and final
messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammed peace and blessings be upon him
who often says the brother to jesus
moses abraham know all the preceding
messengers he didn't come with anything
different he came with the same message
worship the one and only creator that
heavens and earth the creator not his
creation
and he's exposed to it so he's saying
you know he's testing the waters now and
he sees that this is the truth he said
what'd he say he said if i was with him
i'd wash his feet
and drink the water
hold on hold on this is really deep for
people who admire historical figures
like alexander the great and you know uh
they watch many of these movies uh
braveheart and many of these people out
there you know some are even fictional
but now heracl this is a real this is
not someone from the movies
no no the guy
uh gathered all of his priests and monks
and head of church
and ordered his guards to lock the door
and he recited to them
the stories and he recited to them some
of the verses
on
isa peace be upon him jesus christ and
his mother
and
his
miraculous birth
and the priests and monks started crying
until their beards were were wet
christians these are christians crying
now because they're hearing the quran
they are hearing the quran
and miraculous heracles is setting up
this meeting now
now so
after that after he saw them
being so emotionally moved
by the truth of the quran he said to
them so what do you think should we
follow him
so he just
was testing the water in a in a positive
way
they
immediately overturned
because
their love of power
and
love of wealth kicked in
she said and they started rebelling
against him no we will not do this and
so much chaos and
shouting and disturbance
and he knew this this is why he locked
the door from the inside so he said no
no no no calm down calm down i was just
testing your iman if you're real
believers or not
and everything went back to normal
so when this reached the prophet
sallam
he said in arabic
oh this wretched person
he
was
favoring his
wealth and power over islam that's why
he would not give it up
wow
this was unlike
unlike the reaction of
the persian
leader
who torn the letter of the prophet
salallahu
and rejected even to reply to him
because
uh hercules gave
the
messenger who came a gift
and a concubine and some jewelry
back to the protestant as a form of
honoring respect he gave he showed some
respect
to the
level to the level shake of he said i
want people to imagine this he said if i
was with him i would wash his feet and
drink that water
yes out of because
all christians know
of
the one that prophet
isa prophet jesus peace be upon him gave
the glad tidings of his coming
and they knew that there was someone
coming to fix the world and jesus christ
said this in the bible and he said that
he'll come after me he will speak not
from his own self but he would speak
from uh um yeah i'm not a biblical
historian so i i'm not zakir knight
either so you go ahead and check it out
can you get him on the phone real quick
i wish i wish i seriously i can't but
not not that at the moment
so
um
you find
evidences that are beyond doubt
that they knew there was some someone
coming and we know who this someone is
and we can see it through his track
record
just open your eyes what do people hate
about islam
there are those who have
in it
in uh enmity against islam
like some european countries without
naming them
even
when the european council came yesterday
with an ad
showing a woman without hijab half
picture and a woman with hijab
half picture
to show the integrity the
um
how
cultures blend
in europe because muslims are a great
portion of the population in europe it's
an ad a woman with no hijab and a woman
with hijab they blend them in
so half of the girl is without and half
is with what happened this european
country came up front and said
no this is totally unacceptable we
object because this denies the christian
and the jewish heritage of europe
they have hatred to hijab
anything that respects women they have a
problem with if a woman
comes out with a bikini or wearing a
thumb good for you that's the thing
that's what we like to see
they have no
fear no
bashfulness no
shyness
they hate islam full stop
so you with a beard cut it
you wear hijab take it off when corona
came
people started wearing their mask
they they were shocked what can we do
they're wearing nikab legally
they couldn't do anything about it but
when it's out of your conviction out of
your belief out of your religion no we
have a problem it
so these are great examples for morgan
freeman or whoever else doesn't matter
the message is open for every everyone
uh now
you mentioned the persian king you
struck an example contrast here when he
and this also now look if someone wants
to see if the
quran is from the crate of the heavens
and earth they want to take a scientific
analytical approach they will see that
this is indeed from the crate the proof
is overwhelming but then you see these
small details that are there that are
just you know mind-blowing like
this example that you were going to give
with the persian king
there was a prediction in there you can
say something that was going to happen
and can you go ahead and talk about this
when those messengers came
and then the prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him what did he
predict or say something that's going to
happen in the future that they didn't
even know until like what a month's
journey or several weeks journey
when the messengers came and they told
the prophet and he told the prophet it
was one messenger and he told the
prophet that this is what
the persian
emperor did he torn
your letter
unlike
what happened with the christians who
honored it and sent with the gift what
was in the letter
what was the letter about
for people that don't know what's in the
letter
the letter was simply stating that
peace be upon those who follow the
guidance of allah azzawajal
come to islam
and you will be rewarded
for yourself and for all those who fall
you
and if you do not accept islam the
message of allah which is to believe in
monetism which to believe that the
prophet muhammad is the messenger of
allah
then you shall be punished for your sins
and the sins of those who follow you so
it's a call to islam it's an invitation
with sent with an and a messenger
so he
out of arrogance
out of pride he
tore it up
and
sent the messenger back
when the messenger came back to the
prophet elsa and told him
the prophet said two words
allah
he said may allah
tear
his kingdom
and
on that particular day
which the muslims came to know a month
or so later when the news came
on that
particular night
this emperor
was killed
and he had no male offspring so his
daughter took his position in leading
the country which led it to go downhill
and we all know how they were conquered
by the muslims
wow subhanallah so you have this
what is historically documented you have
heracles you have him like you
are bringing to our attention that the
he put all the christians together they
got to hear some of the quran they're
crying weeping
they recognize this as the truth
but they didn't accept because their
power like now what are you going to do
you're going to just live for prestige
power you're going to live for just the
things of this world are you going to
accept the truth but with the truth
there come sometimes consequences right
people rebelling like they were going to
do against him
but then you have other examples
you know uh you gave this example the
persian but then there was also others
christians who also accepted like the
christian king of abyssinia
so this is another example of a
christian can you talk about who now
he
also
was someone who was just who was fair
someone who later did he accept islam
well this was way way back in the
beginning in the early times of islam
the letters to the najaf to the uh
um
to the persian emperor to
the emperor of bahrain which in the
eastern part of saudi arabia the emperor
of
the byzantians the king of coptics of
egypt and to the abyssinian ruler these
were on the ninth year of hijra
which is
22 years
after the revelation started
that was about two years before the
death of the prophet islam
if i'm not mistaken
so it's almost
when people came to accept islam et
cetera this is when it was sent
and it might have been
uh
let me recollect no no i was wrong i was
wrong sorry i apologize um you don't
have to edit this but this just to show
how poor i am and how mistakes i make
this was way back because when it came
to the
abyssinian emperor abu sufyan even
was at the time of the truce between the
muslims and the this the mushrikeen and
this was before the conquest of mecca so
this was before between year six and
year eight of hijrah
this is when it took place now the
abyssinian king you're talking about his
name was
she
he was christian
at the time he was christian but this
incident took place
12 13 years
ago
meaning that when the muslims were
prosecuted in mecca before they migrated
to medina
they were so
finding it difficult to live
to the extent that the prophet hassan
told them listen allah has made way out
for you you may migrate to abyssinia
which means that you have to get on
boats cross the red sea go to a foreign
land with a different language and
nowadays if you're a uh
frequently flyer
and you have uh um access to different
airlines and hotels no problem you can
just come
send me an invitation to kuala lumpur
and i'll come within eight to 10 hours
that time it was
like the difference between life and
death
for for bedouins to go on ships and
cross the sea
not knowing how to swim to a foreign
land whoa
so
they went there now the thing is that
the prophet told them
go there because there is a king
people would not be oppressed under his
reign
and that is one mind-blowing fact
because
for a
a a man who was illiterate who did not
read
and they didn't have any fox news or cnn
at the time yet he knew who the rulers
of countries around him and how they
dealt with their people
this shows you that the amount of
knowledge the prophet had i succeeded
about what was going on so he said to
them go to him so they went
and they asked permission to live in his
country
and the najashi the abyssinian king
allowed them to
after some time
the idol worshipers of quraysh of the
enemies of islam did not like this
so they sent two men
to
try to persuade the king to send them
back
these men and one of them was
asked
with him who was a kafir at the time
they went with lots of gifts
so they gave all the close ones to the
king
particular gifts watches jewelries
golden pens money
so they bought the court of the king
and then they went to the king
and said to him we have a problem with
our locals who came to you their
renegades and they um say bad things
about our gods and idols so we would
like you to send them back with us
we will deal with them all those around
the king says yeah yeah yeah they know
their people
send them back with them we don't need
strangers
and definitely we're not going to build
a wall
like trump's so send them back
so he said no they came and chose my
hospitality and country
how can i return them back
i would not
do this yes
so the following day
went to the king and said
ask them what they say about jesus
because they say something that is
extremely wild and inappropriate
being a christian he said okay i have to
hear what he they say about him
so he gathered them
their spokesman was
the cousin
of the prophet
of course the brother of ali
so he was the spokesman who came in
and gave his speech
and he said i will read you verses from
al-quran
and he read the verses from the quran
portraying the miraculous birth of
jesus christ and what had happened with
his mother
by the time he ended
reciting the quran
tears was filling up
the face of a najashi
and
even
his monks and priests
and he said to them wallahi
is nothing more than what they have
recited
jesus is when yeah
jesus christ this is when the monks and
priests started to
become angry
because it says that jesus
had no father
and there was no male intervention
rather it was
the archangel gibril who planted his
soul
in the womb of mother mary
they did not like this and
the abyssinian cave was unlike the
hercules he
ordered them to shut
up and said that this is the truth
and nothing else is the truth they
conceded
and he told them do whatever you want
you are free to worship allah
in my life
wow
so this is a great you know because a
lot of times people they get kind of a
superficial
understanding about islam morgan freeman
now these are the kind of stories i mean
you have so much
uh isn't there a verse in the quran the
verbatim word of god almighty that allah
is talking about that when there is
amongst them those who when they hear
the truth
you know they shed tears so now you have
an example of the christians during the
time of miraculous and now another
abyssinian king here who later accepted
islam you have them shedding tears
they're hearing the truth
and now morgan freeman or anybody else
can be uh liam neeson again it's
interesting about liam neeson that there
was when he came back because you
mentioned this he was uh in the first
part of his stay in turkey he was
annoyed with the dan and then you know
how the story goes it's an older story
but then he started he said it was
something like it was penetrating his
soul and there was even talk you'd watch
him on some of these talk shows talking
about you know he was like kind of
pumped up but then he got hit with the
backlash from community and that's now
your test are you going to submit to
what he and she says you know the
community or stardom or are you going to
actually go down that path and accept
the truth so these are great stories for
morgan freeman and others to really take
a deep dive and look into islam so what
would you say to someone like morgan
freeman
someone who now they think that just
this is just another religion there's
some good in there just like other
religions and whatnot
but you have clear passages in the quran
where god almighty i mean if you look at
this quran this book there's no way that
it can come from anyone else there's not
contradiction upon contradiction you
know there's not different versions of
the quran uh it's not you know uh
a court a collection of books from
anonymous authors this is from the
creator who created you me and the whole
universe and everything in it and he's
saying that whoever chooses a way of
life other than complete and total
submission to him and him alone to the
creator of the universe never will that
way of life be accepted so what would
you if you had to sit down now he's
traveling morgan freeman he comes to
your part of the world jeddah and he's
doing his documentary and now you're
talking with them what what would you
what are the kind of things how would
you invite him to this beautiful way of
life of islam
usually i
follow a very easy
way
thinking very simple not a rocket
scientist as if rocket science is is the
best and no i'm not someone who's uh
sophisticated i'm an easy going person
i'm easy like friday morning so um i
wouldn't go into complicated stuff
philosophical stuff i don't know this
stuff alhamdulillah i know black and
white i'm a logical person so i would
say to him listen
you believe in the existence of one
creator
most likely he said definitely
okay this
one creator would it be wise
to create all this perfection
in this life in this world and leave
them astray without
showing them what is right and what's
wrong
you wouldn't expect
a apple to produce a device
so magnificent so
sleek so nice and not tell people
whether it's a phone or a tv
set or a microwave
they would have to show them how it
works
operation manual etc so allah azzawajal
definitely would show us how to worship
him what to do and what is expected from
us he said logical
but all religions do this okay excellent
number one
are all religions
right at the side of allah said uh maybe
no no no it can't be
if they are all right they mean that
they all share the same values do they
shame that share the same same values no
no no this religion goes right this
religion goes left this religion does
not even exist on earth so definitely
the truth
beside allah is one
so which one which religion this is the
acid test you have to do to each
religion come to christianity scrutinize
it look into it deeply to see if it is
the accepted religion
to god at the moment
do you have an original scripture of the
new testament of the injil
no we have a translation of a
translation of a translation you have
the
original manuscript no does anybody know
the original manuscript and how no do
you have one virgin no we have hundreds
the catholics have the douay virgin the
protestants
have the king james virgin we have the
new standard virgin we have the red dot
uh virgin or letter
thousands of copies
okay go to other religions hindus
buddhism
do they
share the perfection
the authenticity
the
sustainability of all religions
like islam or not
you will come to the conclusion that
okay
with all religions
ratings i will rate islam to have the
highest eighty percent
let's assume eighty percent not a
hundred percent is there anything close
to it no the second close is like 30 or
45.
okay
so why are you accepting islam oh
because it's 80.
if it's 80 percent
the 80 percent which is right and
correct and authentic should overwhelm
the 20 that have doubtful in your head
though i guarantee you that the future
and the science will prove the other 20
that you're not
being able to buy
it's very
easy
way of communicating
but people who are rigid people who say
no no no no i believe that jesus decreed
my life that jesus cured my perilous
paralysis
that jesus did this
jesus came to me like one american uh
president said
jesus came to him god came to him and
told him to invade other countries
and they said oops sorry i did it again
it was it was a mistake there were no
weapons of mass destruction okay sorry
for the million kills
tough luck next time
subhanallah so uh yeah these are a lot a
lot of things you know just uh simple
facts it's not some hocus pocus stuff
that people throw at you and you got to
put your like intelligence on hold uh
when you were mentioning we were
mentioning all these christians
uh and then scholars you know people of
intellect you had so many people who
were enemies opponents
of the truth but later they became
lovers of the truth they accepted the
truth i mean this is you know when
people study the life
you know from the authentic sources when
they study the life
you know the history of prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him not
through the opponents of islam you have
another chris do you have another
scholar
uh who also if you can just touch upon
this
this was somebody now who's a scholar of
that time who know who knew all the
other you know what they had of the
remnants of the truth of you know of the
of the torah what they had of you know
the teachings of jesus so at that time
whatever he had he studied it and then
when he saw prophet muhammad what did he
recognize him as an impostor or as
indeed that anticipated prophet who was
supposed to be sent the last and final
seal of the prophets
he immediately accepted
accepted him and he said
to him
clearly
when your people would kick you out
prophet said
someone came
with the same religion
no one
came with the same religion that you
came up with except he would face enmity
of his people but
eddie with all due respect when you
bring all these stories
if i were in their shoes i would say
that okay this is history
it might be right it might be wrong
i could find uh maybe one in a million
who was a muslim devout muslim who
rejected islam
so does this
it's not the way the way is that allah
gave you
intellect allah gave you a brain to
think of and to analyze things off you
have to do your due diligence
come and sit and think
is this the system that manages the
whole world without problems or conflict
is this the law that ensures justice to
all regardless of color and he is a man
of color
how did the muslims deal with
blacks
who were among the most
uh prominent of the companions of the
prophet
they were black
and the prophet stated this 15 centuries
ago there is no privilege
for a white over a black
for an arab over an
arab
except with a virtue and the fear of
allah
how powerful
yet it's so simple
talking about you know this pure
monotheism and directing people because
sometimes when you ask someone i've had
experience asking you know the person
who's in his uh late 70s 80s have you
ever thought about the purpose of life
have you ever asked the creator of life
for guidance
so i've interviewed so many people over
the years and when they did this simple
yet profound thing of asking the creator
for guidance alone because
the devil shaitan makes things confusing
oh so many religions they're all the
same just that and the other and so it
makes it so complicated but then you
know how powerful is this to leave
morgan freeman or just the average
layman to now ask ask for the guidance
from the one who created you
whoever asks allah azzawajal
wholeheartedly allah will guide him
i guarantee you this
so i don't ask people to come to islam
i just ask them to ask allah almighty to
guide their heart to the straight path
if they're sincere in that
they will be guided imagine what was
the dua the supplication that our
prophet
used to open his night prayer
and night prayer is something that
people offer
as
a voluntary act it's not part of the
five pillars of islam it's something
that is a bit higher it's a bonus so
people wake up at 3 a.m
an hour or two before
the break of dawn when everybody's
asleep nobody's awake
so
the prophet used to wake up
and his supplication would be
oh lord of jibril archangel gabriel
israel and mikhail the three greatest
angels of all
fathers
o allah the creator of the heavens and
the earth
you praise allah with all of these
beautiful praises you ask so you say
guide me
to what
righteousness and truth
people have disagreed upon
what does that show you it shows you
that even the prophet of allah
is begging allah all the almighty every
single night to guide him
to whatever truth people have differed
upon
because if allah doesn't guide you
you're lost you're
astray and the moment you think of
yourself that oh i'm strong i'm king i'm
the uh the champion i'm the owner of
everything
look at all the celebrities the poor
things
50 years ago who were the
first page
articles all the time
always on the first page their pictures
their events their
they were so beautiful so handsome so
strong
where is all of that
down the drain
50 years later another one bites the
dust then what is going on
don't you think that there is a life
after death
shouldn't you at least know
what's the means of transportation the
accommodation what's awaiting me is it a
sweet a royal suite or is it a room in a
dungeon
i have to figure it out now
the problem the biggest problem is that
such people not only celebrities the
vast majority of the population
they are enslaved to their
desires so when you come to one and say
okay come to islam is it where i cannot
jeopardize my red wine of 1982 that was
a good year
with a big piece of
pork chops
i i can't i can't play with that and
your religion prohibits it
is this all what life is about
you're willing but if your cardiologists
say you have high level of cholesterol
you have to stop this or you're gonna
die next week you got to stop it then
you're on it yeah
you have a problem
think about what awaits you and look for
the right way out
whether it's islam or any other religion
i'm fine with that
but
i i i bet you halal
from one side not from yourself that if
you
ask allah for guidance you will be
guided
and this is what the creator is saying
all my slaves are misguided unless i
guide them so ask me of my guidance
is not the creator this is hadith
very authentic
yes subhanallah so leave us with
something shay what else what do you
leave us with for again morgan freeman
anybody out there the average muslim
what advice do you leave us before we
conclude
if i conclude it by anything they're
going to say oh the sheikh is envious
because he was not awarded any part in
our movies
but
well i if you give me trillions of
dollars i would not ever think of
participating in this life
i've done that i've been there
alhamdulillah and i know
everything about this life that allah
has
blessed me not to be in
i would urge you
it's not your wealth that we're after
it's not your
blue eyes or your mansions or your fame
it's for your own good
look
into what may save you on the day of
judgment
don't put blind folders
so that you don't see don't be like a
race horse that has these folders on the
side of his head so that he doesn't look
right and left and only moves forward
because this is not how it is
seek allah for guidance
and
open your mind to the truth
and the truth shall guide you with the
grace of allah
for the person just one more question
who's never heard this term allah now
that they think allah is a moon god what
are you talking about allah you know i
call on god god
okay i have a series on my youtube
channel
which is called the beautiful names of
allah
and i explained the 102 names authentic
names of allah the almighty that he
called himself in and the greatest name
of all is allah
which all other names direct to
so when you say who is allah you don't
say the most beneficent the most
merciful no when someone asks what is
the most beneficial the most merciful
you say allah
what is the almighty you say allah what
is
the generous
you say allah all names
relate to allah
who is allah
he is the creator of the heavens and the
earth he is the creator of the universe
there was allah and nothing was with him
imagine there was a point of time though
time
is a creation of allah allah was there
and nothing was with him allah is the
creator of this universe and the whole
universe
is
nothing compared to allah except when
you compare a ring to tossed in a desert
so allah is the name
of the only
worthy of being worshiped they call him
god
they call him
[Applause]
other names but this is the name of
allah that he accepted for himself
mentioned in other scriptures
another variations those who study but
this is the name that he acknowledged
himself to be called in islam
don't uh arabic speaking jews and
christians
also call upon god by the name allah
correct they do and even before islam
they used to have names like abdullah so
the father of the prophet salam
who was not a muslim his name was
abdullah
the servant of allah so this is the god
that jesus he called upon by allah and
this is the god that people jesus called
people to worship not himself but they
this is the one that jesus worshiped
also correct
thank you thank you for being with us
again uh here on the dean's show
inshallah we don't let too many years go
by again before we uh have another nice
session like this inshallah
for having and apologize for the
internet connection but you guys are
like five six thousand miles away you
should come closer to saudi inshallah
thank you may allah bless you
foreign